Salut, saviez vous que vous étiez capable d'écrire un livre en 30 jours
Non?
ben moi non plus
Pourtant c'est le principe du Nanowrimo,
alors derrière ce nom bien chelou
se trouve un concept sympa
*Générique*
Le National Novel Writing Month est une idée géniale, que j'ai découverte l'année dernière
le but du jeu c'est décrire 50 000 mots en seulement 30 jours
soit environ 175 pages, c'est à dire ...
un petit roman, comme la guerre des mondes par exemple
Excusez du peu
Le concept phare du créateur du nano, c'est No Plot, No Problem
c'est à dire, il y a pas d'idée, il y a pas de problème
On a pas besoin d'avoir une idée,
pour écrire quelques choses au Nano
à la limite c'est même mieux.
Vous allez devoir séquestrer votre éditeur intérieur
Vous savez pas qui c'est ? C'est la petite voix qui, dans votre tête, fait "Non mais ça c'est pas terrible,
non ça vas-y, refais-le, ça vas-y reprends-le". Vous devez plus l'écouter, pendant un mois, c'est pas le délire.
Une fois n'est pas coutume, vous allez oublier la qualité au bénéfice de la quantité.
Le but, c'est de faire de la matière, et d'écrire ces fichus 1666 mots quotidiens (virgule 2-3 mots).
J'aime beaucoup cette idée parce que c'est une approche complètement "kamikaze" de la création
c'est-à-dire que si vous vous y mettez, vous allez voir que vous allez écrire beaucoup de choses inutiles,
voire des choses idiotes, et c'est très bien comme ça,
le but étant de faire une première création, un premier jet.
Parce qu'au final on s'autorise pas assez à créer sans jugement de valeur, sans porter soi-même
un propre jugement sur ce qu'on est en train de faire en temps réel.
C'est d'abord de faire sortir quelque chose de soi.
C'est l'idée du Nano : on pose des mots, des mots, des mots, des mots, des mots.
On cherche pas à se relire ou à se corriger,
on se juge pas, on se relit pas, et au bout de 30 jours on a 50'000 mots,
on a 175 pages, on a un premier jet.
Et là vous avez tout le temps après de le retoucher, de le reprendre, de remodifier des choses,
d'en supprimer, d'en changer,
peu importe ! Puisque vous avez déjà une matière complète, ce sera beaucoup plus simple
et beaucoup plus motivant.
Alors on peut le faire à n'importe quel moment de l'année, peu importe d'ailleurs y a pas une date précise à respecter
mais il y a un mois qui est commun, qui est global à tout le monde, dans le monde entier
depuis la création du Nano il y a plus de 10 ans, c'est le mois de novembre.
Le monde entier se met à écrire !
L'intérêt de le faire au mois de novembre, c'est qu'on peut rejoindre une communauté qui est dans le même délire que nous
il y a des rencontres, il y a un kick-off (?) qui se fait la veille du lancement où on se retrouve tous,
il y a des rencontres dans des bars, c'est complètement sauvage, c'est organisé sans être organisé
vous-mêmes vous pouvez créer un endroit où les "Nanoteurs" et les "Nanoteuses" vont pouvoir se rejoindre et écrire avec vous
ce sont des espèces de réunions pour s'encourager, pour se stimuler, et pour pas être tout seul à écrire chez soi.
D'ailleurs cette année les Nanoteurs de France ont déclaré la guerre aux Nanoteurs de Norvège et de Corée du Sud,
c'est-à-dire que sur les sites internet, on met le nombre de mots qu'on a écrit quotidiennement
tous les Nanoteurs français se cumulent, on accumule les scores et on compare avec ceux de la Norvège et de la Corée du Sud
Parce que la règle du jeu, c'est quand même l'honnêteté, personne ne viendra vérifier si vous avez bien écrit vos mots quotidiens,
personne viendra voir le contenu, il y a rien d'autre à gagner que la satisfaction personnelle
d'avoir fait son premier jet, de son premier roman ou d'autre chose d'ailleurs.
Et vous l'avez peut-être compris, je suis en plein dedans moi aussi cette année
J'ai découvert le Nano l'année dernière via le super livre qu'avait sorti son créateur Chris Baty,
(dans le milieu on l'appelle Dieu)
je vous mets un lien dans la description vers ce livre, c'est "Comment écrire un roman en 30 jours"
ça explique tous les fondamentaux du Nano, semaine par semaine, c'est stimulant c'est captivant et c'est très très drôle.
En France d'ailleurs nous avons une mascotte également, c'est une espèce de minuteur sous forme de poulet
de cocotte minute en fait.
Y a un site français qui regroupe toutes ces initiatives et qui vous permet aussi d'être épaulés si c'est la première fois que vous le faites,
je vous mets également le lien dans la description, je vous mets tous les liens dont vous pourriez avoir besoin.
Je vous avais partagée le pouvoir ultime de la Deadline quand on avait parlé de la créativité
quand on avait parlé aussi de la procrastination, et bien le Nano est 100% basé sur le pouvoir de la Deadline
et sa puissance créatrice !
N'hésitez pas à tenter l'aventure, même si là on est déjà le 14 novembre peu importe, vous pourrez faire du 14 novembre
au 14 décembre, c'est vous qui choisissez
même si au moment où vous allez prendre votre crayon ou que vous allez vous posez devant votre ordi, vous n'avez aucune idée de ce dont vous allez parler
c'est pas grave, c'est mieux même je vous l'ai dit !
Vous écrivez sans juger de la qualité, mais pour mettre en marche un processus intérieur.
Si y a des Nanoteurs ou des Nanoteuses qui regardent cette vidéo, je vous souhaite bon courage
pour les 25'000 mots qui vous restent environ d'ici la fin du mois
N'hésitez pas d'ailleurs à vous faire connaître dans les commentaires, ou si y en a qui désirent se lancer
vous pouvez me le dire aussi, ça me fera rire de voir un peu qui participe au délire.
Moi de mon côté j'ai un petit peu de retard, mais c'est que j'ai prévu un peu plus que 50'000 mots
mais c'est pas très grave, je vais me rattraper.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo, j'espère que ça vous aura plu
et que ça vous aura ouvert l'esprit à un autre mode de création qui est plus bourrin
mais qui permet de faire sortir des choses de soi même avant de les juger.
N'oubliez pas c'est très important de mettre un pouce en l'air parce que des fois vous aimez bien mais vous oubliez,
c'est dommage quand même, vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaîne avant de partir
et rendez-vous demain à 17h, ciao !